- [Narrator] Here in the south of England,
(whoosh)
behind these beach huts,
is a very weird
and wonderful floating houseboat village.
Well, sometimes it floats,
and other times it sits on mud
because of the tide, but that
doesn't matter right now.
So without further ado,
let's roll the title card.
(ding)
So, let's get to know Hamish.
He has seven boats.
(popping)
He has a microwave as a postbox.
(lid shuts)
He can do this with a saw.
(slaps)
(high-pitched whir)
He has a grand collection of ...
Let's leave that there.
(piano music)
Hamish moved here
32 years ago after falling on tough times.
Where on Earth do you get a
nose cone from a jumbo jet?
(chuckles)
Fair enough.
(sawing)
(hammer bangs)
Now, I know what you're thinking.
Why on Earth is there a bus
or a scrap car on a boat?
(chuckles)
(light music)
(popping)
(sawing)
(light ding)